The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So in this second
lecture we're going to talk
about some design patterns
for parallel programming.
And to tell you a little bit
about what a design pattern is
and why is it useful.
And some of you, if you've
taken object oriented
programming you've probably
already have seen design
patterns before.
So I ended the last lecture with
OK, so I understand some
of the performance implications,
how do I go
about parallelizing
my program?
This is a flyer I found quite
often in books and talks on
parallel programming.
It essentially lays out 4 common
steps for parallelizing
your program.
So often, you start out with
sequential programs. This
shouldn't be surprising since
for a long time as you've
heard in earlier lectures,
people just coded sequential
code and that was just
good enough.
So now the problem is you want
to take that sequential code
or you want to still write
sequential code just because
it's conceptually easier and
you want to be able to
parallelize it so you can map
it down to your parallel
architecture, which in this
example has 4 processors.
So the first step is you take
your sequential program and
you divide it up into tasks.
So during the project reviews,
for example, yesterday when I
talked to each team individually
we sort of talked
about this and you sort of
stumbled on these 4 steps
whether you realized
it or not.
And so you come up with these
tasks and then each one
essentially incapsulates
some computation.
And then you group them
together, so this is some
granularity adjustment and you
map them down to processes.
These are things you can pose
into threads, for example.
And then you have to essentially
plot these down
onto actual processors and they
have to talk with each
other, so you have to
orchestrate to communication
and then finally do
the execution.
So step through each one
of these at a time.
Sort of composition and recall
that just really effects or
just really is effected
by Amdahl's Law.
And that if there's not a whole
lot of parallels in the
application your decomposition
is a waste of time.
There's not really a
whole lot to get.
But what you're trying to do
is identify concurrency in
your application and
figure out at what
level to exploit it.
So what you're trying to do is
divide up your computation
into tasks and eventually
these are going to be
distributed among processors and
you want to find enough of
them so that you can keep
all the processors busy.
And remember that the more of
these that you have this gives
you sort of an upper bound on
your potential speed up.
And as in the rate tracing
example that I showed, the
number of tasks that you
have may vary run time.
So sometimes you might have lot
of arrays bouncing off a
lot of things, and sometimes you
might not have a whole lot
of reflection going on
so number of arrays
will change over time.
And in other applications,
interactions, for example,
between molecules might
change in a
molecular dynamic simulator.
The assignment really
effects granularity.
This is where you've partitioned
your tasks, you're
trying to group them together
so that you're taking into
account, what is the
communication
cost going to be?
What kind of locality am
I going to deal with?
And what kind of synchronization
mechanisms do
I need and how often do
I need to synchronize?
You adjust your granularity
such that you end up with
things that are load balanced
and you try to reduce
communication as much
as possible.
And structured approaches
might work well.
You might look at the code, do
some inspection, you might
understand the application, but
there are some well-known
design patterns which is
essentially the thing we're
going to get to try to
help you with this.
As programmers really, I
think, we worry about
partitioning first. This is
really independent of an
architecture programming
model.
Just taking my application and
figuring out well, what are
different parts that I need to
compose together to build my
application?
So I'm going to show you
an example of that.
And one thing to keep in the
back of your mind is that the
complexity of how much
partitioning work you actually
have to do really effects
your decision.
So if you start out with some
piece of code or you wrote
your code in one way and you
realize that to actually
parallelize it requires so much
more work, in some user
studies we've done on sort of
trying to get performance from
code, it really effects how
much work you actually do.
And if something requires a lot
of work, you might not do
it even though it might have
really hot payoff.
So you want to be able to keep
complexity down, so it pays
off to really think well about
your algorithm, how you
structure it ahead of time.
And finally, the last two stages
I've lumped together.
It's really orchestration
and mapping.
I have my task, they need to
communicate, so what kind of
computation primitives
do I need?
What kind of communication
primitives do I need?
So am I packaging things
up into threads?
And they're talking together
over DMAs or shared memories.
And what you want to do is try
to preserve locality and then
figure out how to come up with
a scheduling order that
preserves overall dependence
of the computation.
Parallel program by patterns is
meant to essentially give
you a cookbook or set of recipes
you can follow to help
you with different steps:
decompose, assign,
orchestrate and map.
This could lead to really
high quality
solutions in some domains.
So in the scientific
computations there's a lot of
problems that are well
understood and well studied
and some of the frequently
occurring things have been
abstracted out and sort of
recorded in patterns.
And there's another purpose to
patterns too, in that they
provide you with the
vocabulary for--
two programmers can talk to each
other and use the right
terminology and that conveys
a whole lot of information
without having to actually
go through and
understand all the details.
You instantaneously know if
I use a particular model.
It can also help with software
reusuability, malleability,
and modularity.
All of those things that are
software engineer perspective
from an engineering perspective
are important.
So brief history and I found
this in some of the talks that
I was researching.
There's a book by Christopher
Alexander from Berkeley in
1977 that actually looked at
classifying patterns or really
listing patterns from an
architectural perspective.
He tried to look at what are
some patterns that occur in
living designs and
recording those.
So as an example, for
example, there's a 6
foot balcony pattern.
So if you're going to build a
balcony you should build it 6
foot deep and you should have it
slightly recessed and so on
because this is what's commonly
used and these are
the kinds of balconies that
have good properties
architecturally.
Now I don't know whether this
book actually had a whole lot
of impact on how people designed
architectures.
Certainly not probably for the
Stata Center, but some
patterns from object oriented
programming, I think, many of
you have already seen these by
the Gang of Four in 1995--
really sort of organized and
classified and came up with
different ways of--
or captured different ways of
programming that people had
been using.
You know, things like the
visitor pattern, for example,
some of you might know.
So in 2005, not too long ago
there was a new book, which
I'm using to create some
of these slides.
Really came up with or recorded
patterns for parallel
programming.
And they identified really
4 design spaces.
I think these are sort of
structured to express or
capture different elements.
So some elements are for the
algorithm expression, I've
listed those here and some are
for the actual software
construction or the actual
implementation.
So under algorithm expression
it's really the thing of
decomposition; finding
concurrency.
Where are my tasks?
In the algorithm structure,
well, you might need some way
of packaging those tasks
together so that they can talk
to each other and be able to
use parallel architecture.
On the software construction
side you're dealing slightly
more low level details.
So what are some things you
might need at a slightly lower
level of implementation to
actually get all the
computation that's expressed at
the algorithm level to work
and run well?
So I'm going to essentially talk
about the latter part in
the next lecture and I'll cover
much of the algorithm
expression stuff here--
at least the fine concurrency
part in this talk.
And if there's time I'll
do algorithm structure.
Otherwise, just talk
about it next time.
So let's say you're working
with MPEG decoding.
This is a pipeline picture of an
MPEG 2 decoder or rather a
blocked level diagram of
an MPEG 2 decoder.
And you have this algorithm
and you say, OK, I want to
parallelize this.
Where's my parallelism?
Where's my concurrency?
You know, in MPEG 2 you have
some bit screen, you do some
decoding on it and you end
up with two things.
You end up with motion vectors
that tell you here's
somebody's head, in the next
scene it's moved to this
particular location.
So these are captured by
the motion vectors.
So this captures or recovers
temporal information.
In here you cover spatial
information.
So in somebody's head you might
have discovered some
redundancies so that redundancy
is eliminated out
so you need to know essentially,
uncompress or
undo that compression.
So you go through some stages.
You combine the two together.
Combine the motion estimation
and now the recovered pictures
to reconstruct the image and
then you might do some
additional stages.
This particular stage here is
indicated to be data parallel
in that I can do different
scenes for example in parallel
or I might be able to do
different slices of the
picture in parallel.
So I can essentially take
advantage of data parallelism
in the concept of taking a loop
and breaking it up as I
showed in lecture 5.
So in task decomposition what
we're looking for is really
independent coarse-grain
computation.
And these often are inherent to
the algorithm. so here I've
outlined these in yellow here.
You know, so this is one
particular task.
I can have one thread of
execution doing all the
spatial decomposition.
I can have another
thread decoding
all my motion vectors.
And in general, you're looking
for sequences of statements
that operate together
as a group.
These could be loops or they
could be functions.
And usually you want these to
essentially just fall out of
your algorithm as
it's expressed.
And a lot of cases it does, so
depending on how you think
about the program you might
be able to find
these quicker or easier.
Data decompositions, which
I've highlighted here
essentially says you have the
same computation applied to
lots of small data element.
You know, you can take your
large data element, partition
it into smaller chunks and do
the computation over and over
in parallel and so that allows
you to essentially get that
kind of data parallelism,
expansion of space.
And finally, I'm going to
make a case for pipeline
parallelism, which essentially
says, well, I can recognize
that I have a lot of stages in
my computation and it does
help to actually have this kind
of decomposition just
because you're familiar
with pipelining
concepts from other domains.
So this type of producer
consumer chain is actually
beneficial.
So it does help to sort of
expose these kinds of
relationships.
So what are some guidelines for
actually coming up with
your task decomposition?
Where do you start?
You have your algorithm, you
understand the problem really
well, you're writing some code
and the hope is that in fact,
as I've pointed out, it does
happen that you can look for
natural code regions that
incapsulate your computation.
So function calls, distinct
loop iterations are pretty
good places to start looking.
And it's easier as a general
rule, it's easier to start
with as many tasks as possible
and then fuse them to make the
more coarse-grained than to
go the other way around.
It impacts your software
engineering decisions, it
impacts software implementation,
it impacts how
you incapsulate things at
low level details of
implementation.
So it's always easier to
fuse than to fizz.
And you want to consider
three things.
You want to keep three things
in mind: flexibility,
efficiency, and simplicity.
So flexibility says if you made
some decisions, is that
really going to scale well or
is it going to allow you to
sort of make the decisions,
changes?
So you might want to have
fixed tasks versus
parameterized tasks,
for example.
So the loops that I showed in
the previous talk, each loop
that I parallelized had a hard
coded number that said, you're
going to do 4 iterations.
That may work well or it
may not work well.
You know, I can't reuse that
code now if I want to
essentially use that kind of
data decomposition and work
sharing if I have a longer loop
and I want a longer array
and I want each thread
to do more work.
So you might want to
parameterize more things in
your tasks.
The efficiency, in that you have
to keep in mind that each
of these tasks will eventually
sort of have to talk with
other tasks.
There's communication costs
that have to be taken into
account, synchronization.
So you want these tasks to
actually amortize the
communication costs or other
overheads over to computation.
And you want to keep in mind
that there's going to be
dependencies between these tasks
and you don't want these
dependencies to get
out of hand.
So you want to keep things
under control.
And lastly, which is probably as
important as the other two:
simplicity.
And that if you start
decomposing your code into
different chunks and you can't
then understand your code in
the end, it doesn't help you
from debugging perspective,
doesn't help you from a
software engineering
perspective or not being able
to reuse you code or other
people being able to understand
your code.
Guidelines for data
decomposition are sort of similar.
And you essentially have to do
task and data parallelism to
sort of complete your process.
And often your task
decomposition dictates your
data partitioning.
So if I've split up a loop into
two different processes
I've essentially implied how
data should be distributed
between these two threads.
And data composition is a good
starting point as opposed to
task parallelism as a
good starting point.
If you're doing the same
computation over and over and
over again, over really, really
large data sets, so you
can essentially use that as your
stick to decide whether
you do task decomposition first
or data decomposition
first.
I've just listed two common
data decompositions.
I'll talk about more of these
later on when we talk about
actual performance
optimizations.
So you want to decompose arrays
for example, along rows
or columns.
You can compose arrays into
blocks, you decompose them
into blocks.
You have recursive
data structures.
So a tree, you might partition
it into left and right
sub-trees in a binary tree.
And the thing you're trying to
get to is actually start with
a problem, and then recursively
subdivide it until
you can get to a manageable
part.
Do the computation and figure
out a way to do the
integration.
You know, it's like merge
sort, classic example --
tries to capture this
really well.
So again, the three theme, key
concepts to keep in mind when
you're doing data decomposition:
flexibility,
efficiency, and simplicity.
The first two are really just
meant to suggest that the size
of the data that you've
allocated actually leads to
enough work.
Because you want to amortize the
cost of communication or
synchronization, but you also
want the amount of work that's
generated by each data chunk
to generate about the same
amount of work, so
load balancing.
And simplicity, just for same
reason as task decomposition
can get out of hand,
data decomposition
can get out of hand.
You don't want data moving
around throughout and then it
becomes again, hard to debug or
manage or make changes and
track dependencies.
Pipeline parallelism, this is
actually classified somewhere
else in the book.
Actually, lifted it up and tried
to make a case for it in
that it's just good nature I
think, to expose producer
consumer relationships
in your code.
So if I have a function that's
producing data that's going to
be used by another function as
with the spatial decomposition
or in different stages of
classic rate tracing
algorithms you want to maintain
that producer
consumer relationship or that
asembly line analogy.
And what are some prime examples
of pipelines in
computer architecture?
It's like the instruction
pipeline
and your super scalar.
But there might be some other
examples of pipelines, things
that you might have used
in say, UNIX shell.
So cat processor, pipe
it to another--
to a grep word and then
word count that.
So I think it's a
natural concept.
We use it in many different ways
and it's good to sort of
practice that at the software
level as well.
And there are some computations
in specific
domains, like in signal
processing and graphics that
have really sort of--
where the pipeline model is
really important part of how
computation gets carried out.
You know, you have your graphics
pipeline for example,
in signal processing.
How much time do I have?
How am I doing on time?
PROFESSOR: OK, should
I stop here?
AUDIENCE: About how much more?
PROFESSOR: 10 slides.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this is sort
of a brief summary, which will
lead into a much larger talk at
the next lecture on how you
actually go about re-engineering
your code for
parallelism.
And this could come into play
if you start with sequential
code and you're parallelizing
it.
Some of you are doing that
for your projects.
Or if you're actually writing
code from scratch and you want
to engineer that for parallelism
as well.
So I think it's important to
sort of understand the problem
that you're working with.
So you want to survey your
landscape, understand what
other people might have done,
and look for well-known
solutions and common pitfalls.
And the patterns that I'm going
to talk about in more
detail really provide you with a
list of questions to sort of
help you assess the existing
code that you're working with
or the problem that you're
trying to solve.
There's something that you need
to keep in mind that sort
of effect your overall
correctness.
So for example, is your
computation numerically stable?
You might know if you have a
floating point computation you
might not be able to reorder
all the operations because
that might effect your
actual precision.
And so your overall output might
be different and that
may or may not be acceptable.
So a lot of scientific codes for
example, are things that
have to deal with a lot of
precision, might have to be
cognizant of that fact.
You want to also define the
scope of, what are you trying
to do and will it
be good enough?
You want to do back of the hand,
back of the envelope
calculations to make sure that
things that you're suggesting
of doing are actually feasible,
that they're
actually practical and that
will give you the sort of
performance expectations
that you've set out.
You also want to understand
your input range.
You might be able to specialize
if there are some
cases for example, that you're
allowed to ignore.
So these are good things
to keep in mind.
You also want to define
a testing protocol.
I think it's important
to understand--
you started out with some piece
of code, you're going to
make some changes to it,
how you going to go
about testing it?
How you might go about debugging
it and that could be
essentially where you spend
a lot of your time.
And then having these things
in mind, I think, the parts
that are worth looking
at are the parts that
make the most sense.
Where is your computation
spending most of its time?
Is there hot spots
in your code?
And you can use profiling tools
for that and in fact,
you'll see some of that for
cell in some of the
recitations later
in the course.
So a simple example of molecular
dynamics simulator.
What you're trying to do is,
you have some space of
molecules, which I'm just going
to represent in 2D.
You know, look, they have water
molecules and I have
some protein that I'm trying
to understand how the
different atoms in that molecule
are moving around so
that I can determine the
shape of the protein.
So there are forces,
there are bonded
forces between the molecules.
So I've just shown for example,
bonded forces among
my protein and then there
are non-bonded forces.
So how are different atoms sort
of interacting with each
other because of electrostatic
forces, for example.
So what you try to do is figure
out, on each atom, what
are all the forces that are
affecting it and what is its
current position and then you
try to estimate where it's
going to move based on
Newtonian, in the simplest
case, a Newtonian f equals
m a type projection.
So in a naive algorithm you have
n squared interactions.
You have to calculate all the
forces on one molecule from
all others.
By understanding your problem
you know that you can actually
exploit the properties of
forces that essentially
decrease exponentially, so you
can use a cutoff distance.
So if a molecule is way too far
away you can ignore this.
And for people who do galaxy
calculations, you know you can
ignore geometric forces between
constellations or
clusters that are
too far apart.
So in the sequential code, some
pseudo code for doing a
molecular dynamic simulator,
you have your atoms array,
your force array, your set of
neighbors in a two-dimensional
space and you're going to go
through and sort of simulate
different time steps.
And for each time step you're
going to do-- for each atom--
compute the bonded forces,
compute who are my neighbors
for those neighbors, compute--
so these are things that
essentially incapsulate
distance.
Compute the forces between
them, update the
position and end.
So since this is a loop then
that might suggest essentially
where to start looking
for concurrency.
So you can start with the
decomposition patterns and
they'll be more in depth details
about those next.
I'm going to give you some
intuition and then you would
try to figure out whether your
decomposition has to abide by
certain dependencies and what
are those dependencies?
How do you expose them?
And then, how can you
design and evaluate?
How can you evaluate
your design?
Screwed up again.
I just fixed this.
OK, so this is the pseudo code
again from the previous slide.
And since all you have is a
simple loop that essentially
says, this is where to look
for the computation.
And since you're essentially
doing the same computation for
each atom then that again,
gives you the type of
parallelism that we've
talked about before.
So you can look for splitting
up each iteration and
parallelizing those so that each
processor for example,
does one atom.
Or each processor does a
collection of atoms. But there
are additional tasks.
So data level parallelism
versus sort of control
parallelism.
For each atom you also want
to calculate the forces.
You want to calculate long
range interactions, find
neighbors, update position
and so on.
And some of these have shared
data, some of them do not.
So you have to factor that in.
So understanding there control
dependencies essentially tells
you how you need to it lay
out your orchestration.
So you have your bonded forces,
you have your neighbor
list, that effects your long
range calculations.
But to do this update position
I need both of these tasks to
have completed.
And in each one of these tasks
there's different data
structures that they need.
So everybody essentially reads
the location of the items. So
this is good because we want
time step that essentially
says, I can really distribute
this really well, but then
there's a right synchronization
problem
because eventually I have to
update this array so I have to
be careful about who goes
first. There's an
accumulation, which means
I can potentially do a
reduction on these.
There's some write on the other
end, but that seems to
be a localized data structure.
So for partitioning example,
neighbors might have to be
just locals at a different
processor.
So coming up with this structure
and sort of block
level diagram helps you
essentially figure out where
are your tasks?
Helps you figure out what kind
of synchronization mechanisms
you need and it can also help
you suggest the data
distribution that you might need
to reduce synchronization
costs and problems. And
lastly, you want to
essentially evaluate
your design.
And you want to keep in mind,
what is your target
architecture.
Are you trying to really run
on shared memory and
distributed memory and message
passing or are you just doing
this for one architecture?
So for your project, you're
doing this for self, so you
can be very self specific.
But if you're doing this
in other contexts, the
architecture actually
might influence
some of your decisions.
Does data sharing have
enough special
properties like a read only?
There are data structures
that are read only.
Are there enough accumulations
that you can exploit by
reductions?
Are there temporal constraints
on data sharing
that you can exploit?
And can you deal with
those efficiently?
If you can't then you
have a problem.
So you need to resolve that.
If the designs OK then
you move on to
the next design space.
So at the next lecture
I'll go through these
in a lot more detail.
That's it.